but speaking of bakki obviously bucky's
the [ __ ] idol since his daughter yeah
b stars [ __ ] amazing master that's
that's like the newest one that's on
that's probably the newest one like i
after i finished reading b stars i was
like oh that is so close to a modern
masterpiece how come um
i don't know
like for me bucky is one of those shows
where it's like
it's good don't get me wrong it's
[ __ ] amazing and it's so unique yeah
but
i feel that it's like there are some
parts where it's just like
it's just a blur when you're ready you
know what i mean or it's like it's so
long and there's so much [ __ ] that
happens in it that is just so insane and
ridiculous
you think of one fight scene and it
blends in with about 10 other fighters
that's just true it's true right like
part two for example right with the
whole tournament off yeah like i'm just
like i can only remember maybe like one
or two fights i re-write at the other
level there's like 20 fights in the
manga yeah in the enemy then he showed
like four yeah right but that's probably
cause most of them are kind of
underwhelming yeah true true a lot of
the fight even in the anime there was
only then you should like six and i was
like ah three of these like with bucky
you remember the most like notable like
meanwhile the ridiculous type of scenes
right whereas with uh b stars for
example it was like
just as like one cohesive story it was
just a really [ __ ] unique yeah really
done well and it's just yeah has it
concluded yep it ended when did they
finish it could have been too long about
a year ago so how many seasons of the
anime do you think should be if we were
to adapt everything to adapt everything
yeah so
we're at season two right now which is
uh she probably shouldn't say
where we're up to in season two but
that's probably about
volume
seven or eight how many volumes are
there over twenty
so well
it wasn't season three announced already
i think so yeah i'm sure i'm sure
netflix wants to keep that that coming
and yeah i am very happy with that and
it gets different it gets more and more
interesting after that because i'm
hoping we finally get a [ __ ] anime
that finishes in anime form we never
[ __ ] get it anymore we're getting it
like the latest one i can think of that
we're getting is is attack on titan and
that's only like one of the most
successful anime
it's like it's like the streets are like
start new anime yeah finish old one and
then like
i like
no
stop finish this one finish because it's
just like if an anime gets over three
seasons like because even even if we get
a season two that's just like that's
just like getting the table scraps right
you're like oh my god i can't believe
i've got a season two oh ova
[Music]
i have some more
and then for some reason there's like
[ __ ] four seasons of mahoka or
something i'd like
what's going on there's a [ __ ] spin
off of my hook nobody else's i'll be
like [ __ ] ten seasons of saki like
playing mashup
oh [ __ ] off [ __ ] off is this doing well
you cannot tell me this this deserves a
second season no game no life doesn't
[ __ ] right yeah
but uh yeah so b stars so you think it's
like up there's a modern classic now
because i i i think so the ending wasn't
exactly like amazing amazing like it was
just a solid ending if we get the full
anime adaptation of the manga in the way
that it's going right now it would be
considered a masterpiece
man i personally would see it as like a
easy like nine out of ten at least i
mean i mean i i can i can see that
if if the anime keeps up the quality of
the story because i love season one but
it felt like season one just felt like
it's kind of a setup season it's like
the the ending of b stars is very much
like the ending of part six where it's
like the people who love it love it but
the people who didn't like it were like
you know
yeah i mean it's like a lot of people
say that it's like kind of an
anti-climactic ending but i thought it
was kind of fitting to how the entire
story went because like
the final part of beast does there's
like this big fight that happens
obviously of course but and and then
from that big fight it kind of suddenly
winds down into just like regular stuff
okay and like to a lot of people that
was seen as anti-sometimes i like that
though i like a little breathing time to
say goodbye yeah right you know what i
mean i like to uh all right guys just
kind of read a few more chapters with
you guys before you guys [ __ ] off
forever yeah
because like what what gets me sometimes
is i know like
there's always the hype around the last
chapter right because the last chapter
you saying goodbye to everything and you
know this is this is where this is and
people like tried to put a conclusion in
the last chapter where some of like my
favorite manga is when that last chapter
is just the climax is over it's done
it's purely just an epilogue and i feel
like epilogues are so [ __ ] underrated
in so many anime and manga because most
of the time it's just like you get to
the final episode right and half of this
episode is the climax so you got like 10
minutes to say goodbye to all these
characters
yeah give me a screen i hate the
epilogues that are like there's like
like seven minutes left of the episode
it's like yeah are they gonna are they
gonna stick the landing and then you
know that it's a rushed epilogue when
they start talking and the ending song
plays yeah no no no
and it's not even it's not even an
epilogue it's just like a slideshow of
just like here here are the characters
now
oh here they go